[Music]
in fast food food news oh I know it is
submitted by pet penguins so much
alliteration in this food I think I know
what it is
a man called in the drive-thru window to
fight Popeye staff after selling out of
their new chicken sandwiches bath salts
it's bad addicting a Dicky it's a it's
easy it's a meme right now man like
people are going crazy for this [ __ ]
like people are like it's like it's like
Black Friday
ha my chicken sandwiches yeah people are
going crazy over there like it sold out
and then that's it's it's been all over
like Twitter Instagram whatever I don't
understand this [ __ ] it all started when
Popeyes announced on August 12th that
they have a chicken sandwich it says
chicken brioche pickles new sandwich
Popeyes nationwide so good forgot to how
to speak and complete an I mean
sentences that's the tweets can we give
some for lunch we can't because they're
also they're also about like as soon as
they have it yeah everyone just keeps
eating them yeah so then that was the
first one I never even got a chance me
too and then chick-fil-a chimes in and
they ended up tweeting out bond +
chicken + pickles equals all the love
for the original but they're different
though that Popeyes came in and said yo
good oh all of a sudden it's like a
black person fighting a white person
that's what it feels like branding yeah
like a white chicken sandwich company
bros a black chicken
not just that but they've been in
trouble for like a lot of like
homophobia jibley chick-fil-a yeah cuz
they're like run by really religious oh
yeah post on Sundays instead and Popeyes
around by black gay guys ah I just want
to make them complete opposites I don't
know I would understand the Worthen
Wendy's come in oh oh they did want to
yeah Wendy said y'all out here fighting
about which of these fools has a second
best chicken sandwich why is she talking
like no because she's like copying
Popeye talk like that
I hear find about these fools it has the
second best chicken sandwich get fired I
don't know what right imagine it's just
one person running all of the social
media job you don't respect that person
also running in there fighting they're
all fighting each other that's not even
the same category that's a white person
shaking sandwich well they're all
fighting on what chick-fil-a's well
chick-fil-a yes - but that's not even a
white chick-fil-a really charming cuz
Popeyes is based off of the like
tennessee hot style whatever right well
yes because of the brioche with pickles
and chicken sandwich like that
combination they're like they wanted to
come in and say yeah you can't throw the
chicken in there cuz that's a different
kind of I saw internet name with that
you guys remember when McDonald's had
the southern fried chicken with pickles
in it I don't know I haven't eaten in a
while but they it was good but then
Popeyes came in responding to Wendy's
and said sounds like someone just ate
one of our biscuits because y'all
looking thirsty battling it out tear
themselves down to clap back at someone
else they're like following and so
Popeyes Twitter followers have like shut
up like crazy I want to see a celebrity
boxing match with all three of those
CEOs yeah that's like the Tennessee hot
sandwich or whatever like that's that
category so there's like insane amount
of hype and then people posting these
photos ya know it's bomb percent agree
with the hype it's [ __ ] bomb have you
seen the photo of chick-fil-a putting
their chicken in a bucket and then
they're like we don't try to do what
we're not or whatever it was chick-fil-a
and then they put a bunch of like
chicken in that bucket making fun of pop
there fellas
real thing is an official thing know
it's official thing our style
I thought faking and a meme on the
McDonald's one with the mix shake in and
says when they run out of money they'll
come back damn but yeah so now I will
show you guys this video that went viral
because someone was very upset that they
ran out of the chicken sandwiches and
then they climbed through the
drive-through window and started
fighting with the snow were they
supposed to do that just like the
Wendy's mascot I think fast food makes
people go crazy like crackheads I'm
gonna kick myself take a sandwich no
that's like a bigger dude one guy got
manager something cuz you need a
different shirt it's not red he's in a
blue button up he's got a little
chokehold on it lady drop it in the [ __ ]
like he was the one that planted in the
[ __ ] window he's just like give me
one Oh Gemma if all these chicken
sandwiches are causing like all this
mass riots should we be banning them
right dude KFC is doing a vegan one
vegan chicken yeah I don't know there's
there's some sort of controversy with
KFC right now I don't know too much
about I just saw like some people
posting stuff on Twitter I'm really bad
at the tea but I did see that they were
serving like vegan chicken heard about
that to you
what I mean is that controversy
everywhere I like louisiana-style fried
chicken and I wish that their business
was better because they could be
somebody but they're not it's like it's
like that it's like someone with a lot
of substance but they don't have a lot
of confidence
I just checked chick-fil-a's Twitter and
they changed their bio too we didn't
invent the chicken just the chicken
sandwich oh there's no way there's no
way shape fillet can say they invented
the chicken sandwich yeah it's just
bread and chicken
yeah there's no way you know what sucks
though is um I kind of feel that like
there's always small mom-and-pop
companies like how the race that like
but it's all across the station I mean
it's not station they're all across the
nation it's like the Tennessee like hot
sandwich or whatever right but it's so
easy for these big companies to just
come in and see something that's popping
in like a bubble and just kind of in my
eyes steal it that's like every industry
I know it just sucks - thank you very 21
yeah even with like CrossFit it's like
finally you have like these little
warehouse gyms and then 24 hour comes
and goes oh that's what you guys are
doing boom here's gonna be like an
entire 10,000 square foot space in our
gym now that's gonna have everything
that I saw these little CrossFit gyms
out and it's like damn can't people just
keep things like original and you just
stick to your business model I think
it's dope that Popeyes is doing it but
leave the other companies that
capitalism yeah that's what I was just
gonna say I know but that's how it
worked I wish there was more respect but
I understand that a company like Popeyes
they're like specializes chicken would
have a chicken sandwich that's true like
makes total sense to me but do it a
Popeye style and not copy something that
I've seen like I can I know exactly what
they're pulling inspiration from you
know how to raise yeah but if they don't
do it then one of the other big ones way
KFC's gonna ban it I go to Popeyes for
the biscuits mmm I'll go there first
super oily chicken I think I'm a lesbian
you just go and you're like biscuits
please walk out yeah I'm definitely not
crawl through the drive-through window
for it but I mean they're good bisque
yeah but we're not to the point we're
just gonna order biscuit actually I
can't see biscuits more dry though right
we are but three
to put on the butter in the hunt like
the Pillsbury ones where you just pull
back a layer and there's like a leather
layer and the layer like and it's all
thin it's all good
but the churches has the best one I was
yes it was like all right yeah which is
the one that chokes you the chokes
clearly pop I like their fake [ __ ]
mashed potato
KFC's it's like fake ass book where does
it made out of I don't know but it's not
it doesn't you potatoes so soft
yeah it's a potato powder or some [ __ ]
like Hamburger Helper balm when I was
young I don't think I've assessed over
anything that hard that I want to wait
in mind and then get pissed when I don't
get something then I waited in line for
yeah it's pretty intense
like are you a foodie no but I'm just
saying in general like friggin or to
meet someone or to buy something like I
I'm just not have you ever been hopped
up on steroids and then you smoke weed
and then it's like oh I got the munchies
and I got a rage because then I think
you could put yourself in that headspace
okay okay yeah yeah being angry I I can
feel that I know what that feels that's
poor planning then on their part because
if they know they got hangry and then
there's like the [ __ ] for our our
weight they [ __ ] that I don't think
there's no way that there's like a like
an outline drive-through wait yeah that
could be real for puppies sandwiches
yeah and it takes that long like well I
don't know how long but I know people
we're waiting in like crazy and I've
seen friends cuz everyone's posting it
online right now they're like oh it only
took me like an hour and a half to get
this but do it was a bomb I'm like
there's no way I could wait in line now
could make your own
that's board we're all in like the other
post makes this I can't like check right
now for your post base right now see
it's like your wait time is five hours
but then I'm also thinking like maybe
because of the hype it tastes better
yeah maybe they get into that I glaze oh
I hope it was worth the wait
imagine they waited two hours they bite
it they're like fog is garbage yeah but
I think it has to taste good to create
hype right cuz word of mouth for sure
not really nothing
social media it's like Oh like it tastes
good the hypes there and then also in
the hype gets like bigger than the tape
that's true cuz there's times when I'm
like oh it's gonna be so good and then
the you wait a long time and then you
finally sit down you're like it just
looks good for pictures this [ __ ] tastes
like [ __ ] garbage yeah I just want to
be like compliments to the [ __ ] chef
and slam his [ __ ] head with the plate
I want to do that Wow see so I know that
feeling of like but the reverse feeling
of I don't it's not like I want a
sandwich it's like how dare you make me
[ __ ] wait for your [ __ ] food like if
I have like a six out of ten chicken
sandwich that I waited like six minutes
for and then I have like a nine out of
ten chickens how much they waited like
an hour for I might still go for the
yeah I think you're a busy man what do
you have [ __ ] to do you do the other
thing
and I don't have [ __ ] to do and I want
the nine out of ten nine out of ten all
the way to you never crave anything and
you're just like I need this right now
no matter what yeah and I'll [ __ ]
wait oh wow I'll [ __ ] climb [ __ ]
Everest for this [ __ ] that's so hard for
me cuz like when I get to the top I'm a
bite that chicken sandwich and go [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] I don't want to sugar
cane just for a month see but you gotta
like pre-plan that like when you're like
you just don't have any passions
goddammit I'm hungry now I want this so
in an hour and a half it's gonna be
great yeah versus like oh I'm hungry I
need to eat and it's like you go to a
restaurant the wakes an hour it's like
you're planning I gotta go eat somewhere
else because I'm hungry no that's not
the point though planning is boring I
just gotta talk about you just kind of
wake up one day and say I'm going to
France because I want a sparkling
[ __ ] the last time that the hype
was worth it for me that was something
came out that was like really reflects
was Krispy Kreme always worth it
remember when Krispy Kreme first came
out though and lines out the door it was
like people for real thought that was
like drugs in the village that was
falling down we just kind of watched
last week oh you did all the time you
guys you know when the light is on that
means it's actually baking right now oh
it's not baking but it's being May right
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]